paul of tarsus has done more than any
other person in history to influence and
shape conceptions about the person and
message of jesus
in this video we are going to consider
the question is paul a reliable source
of information about jesus
the early followers of jesus were hunted
and persecuted by paul who started out
as a zealous enemy of christianity
then one day while on a sandy desert
road to damascus paul said they had a
mystical encounter with a disembodied
voice claiming to be jesus
from there paul went on to become a
super evangelist dedicating his life to
spreading what he claimed was the
message of jesus
paul's biggest claim to legitimacy as an
apostle is the divine revelation which
he said he received directly from jesus
for example paul wrote i want you to
know brothers and sisters that the
gospel i preached is not of human origin
rather i received it by revelation from
jesus christ
unfortunately there is no way of
independently verifying paul's claims of
mystical desert encounters with jesus we
just have to take him at his word
what we can do to test paul's
apostleship is to scrutinize his
writings
he made repeated claims of divine
inspiration and since god is all-knowing
and all-wise it stands to reason that
paul's writings should be free of error
in the following prophecy paul provided
a timeline for the world's end
we will not all sleep but we will all be
changed in a flash in the twinkling of
an eye at the last trumpet
for the trumpet will sound the dead will
be raised imperishable and we will be
changed
sleep here is being used as a metaphor
for death so paul seems to be saying
that not all of the believers in his day
would die before the return of jesus
obviously this is a false prophecy as it
has been nearly 2 000 years since paul
wrote these words and the return of
jesus still has not taken place
in fact many new testament scholars and
thinkers conclude that paul and his
followers expected the imminent end of
the world
for example the distinguished new
testament scholar professor c k barrett
wrote in his commentary on this prophecy
paul expects that at the parousia second
coming of jesus he himself will not be
among the dead of whom he speaks in the
third person but among the living of
whom he speaks in the first person he
expected the parousia within his own
lifetime
a virtually identical end-of-world
prophecy can be found in the gospel of
mark the renowned christian apologist c
s lewis wrote that it is the most
embarrassing verse in the bible
now some christians try to defend paul
by claiming that when he made the
statement we will not all sleep he was
not including the believers of his day
among those who will not taste death but
rather he was referring to believers at
some unspecified time in the future
so what did paul intend by a statement
shall we interpret it literally or
figuratively
we can look to paul's related prophecies
to help us arrive at the correct
understanding
in the following prophecy paul advised
believers with regards to how they
should conduct themselves going forward
but those who marry will face many
troubles in this life and i want to
spare you this what i mean brothers and
sisters is that the time is short from
now on those who have wives should live
as if they do not
those who mourn as if they did not
those who are happy as if they were not
those who buy something as if it were
not theirs to keep
those who use the things of the world as
if not engrossed in them for this world
in its present form is passing away
note paul's statements about marriage
emotions and materialism
believers are told that all such
activities are futile as time is short
and the world is passing away believers
are advised to avoid such things from
now on i.e with immediate effect going
forward
this is clear proof that paul genuinely
believed that the world's end was
imminent otherwise his advice about
living as bachelors not feeling human
emotions and being completely detached
from material things is nonsensical as
christians would have been unnecessarily
going about life as celibate emotionless
ascetics for nearly 2 000 years and
counting
this is highly problematic when we
consider the standard that the old
testament lays out for true divine
inspiration
if what a prophet proclaims in the name
of the lord does not take place or come
true that is a message the lord has not
spoken
we can see that according to the bible
itself anyone who makes a claim about
the future which then fails to come true
cannot be inspired by god
one of paul's core teachings is the idea
that salvation is achieved through faith
in jesus alone and not any kind of works
as paul informed us but what does it say
the word is near you it is in your mouth
and in your heart
that is the message concerning faith
that we proclaim
if you declare with your mouth jesus is
lord and believe in your heart that god
raised him from the dead you will be
saved
here paul is quoting from the old
testament in order to lend support to
his theology that we are saved by faith
alone and not works
let's take a look at the original
passage in the book of deuteronomy
the word is very near you it is in your
mouth and in your heart so you may obey
it
notice the problem paul has taken the
quarter of its original context he left
out the part that states so you may obey
it
in other words paul has omitted god's
command to obey the mosaic law
we can see that the original passage in
the old testament actually establishes
the opposite of what paul intended works
are indeed important
another of paul's core teachings is the
idea that all of god's covenantal
promises to abraham were fulfilled by
the coming of jesus as paul informed us
the promises were spoken to abraham and
to his seed scripture does not say
antecedes meaning many people but unto
your seed meaning one person who is
christ
here paul is making the argument that
god's promise to abraham did not speak
of seeds in the plural but rather seed
in the singular and concludes that the
single seed is a reference to one man
i.e jesus
let's take a look at the original
passage in the book of genesis
and i will establish my covenant with
him for an everlasting covenant and with
his seed after him
the original hebrew word used for seed
is zera which is a collective noun that
can be used to refer to both a single
descendant or many descendants it
depends on the context in which it
appears this is just like the english
language for example the word sheep can
mean one sheep or many depending on the
context
so how should we interpret the mention
of seed in the old testament we find an
answer in the same book of genesis
and i will make thy seed as the dust of
the earth so that if a man can number
the dust of the earth then shall thy
seed also be numbered
here god promised abraham that he will
be blessed with a multitude of
descendants
likening his seed to the dust of the
earth
therefore we can see that the correct
context for seed is not a single seed as
paul incorrectly interpreted it but
rather many
paul taught that the nation of israel
will be saved from its sins through
jesus as paul informed us and in this
way all israel will be saved as it is
written the deliverer will come from
zion he will turn godlessness away from
jacob
here paul has quoted from the old
testament book of isaiah
the redeemer will come to zion to those
in jacob who repent of their sins
declares the lord
note the clear mismatch paul's quote
mentions that the savior will remove sin
from israel whereas the book of isaiah
states that their savior will come to
israel after is repented from sin
just what is going on here
paul may have been quoting from the
septuagint a greek version of the old
testament
and the deliverer shall come for sion's
sake and shall turn away ungodliness
from jacob
we can see that paul's quote closely
matches the greek septuagint
it turns out that there are two variant
readings of the old testament the one in
hebrew and the greek septuagint that
paul seems to have quoted from
there is in fact strong evidence that
the greek septuagint contains a later
reading this is because the dead sea
scrolls the oldest surviving manuscripts
for the old testament support the
reading that is found in the hebrew
scriptures
this means that when paul chose to quote
from the greek septuagint he unknowingly
used the later incorrect reading god
obviously would not have inspired him to
make such a mistake
paul argued that nobody can achieve
righteousness through the works of the
mosaic law as paul informed us as it is
written there is no unrighteous not even
one there is no one who understands
there is no one who seeks god
their throats are open graves their
tongues practice deceit
the poison of vipers is on their lips
their mouths are full of cursing and
bitterness
their feet are swift to shed blood
there is no fear of god before their
eyes
therefore no one will be declared
righteous in god's sight by the works of
the law
what paul quotes here is a compilation
of six separate passages from the old
testament book of psalms and isaiah he
has strung them together to appear as
one quote
let's examine one of the passages that
paul referenced from psalm 14
the fool says in his heart there is no
god they are corrupt their deeds are
vile there is no one who does good
do all these evildoers know nothing
they devour my people as though eating
bread
they never call on the lord but there
they are overwhelmed with dread for god
is present in the company of the
righteous
we can see that the original passage is
talking about those who say there is no
god
it is these people who are said to do no
good such evildoers are then contrasted
with a second group of people referred
to as my people who are said to be the
company of the righteous
it turns out that paul has distorted
this passage it does not say as paul
quotes it that no human being is
righteous rather it says that those who
deny god are not righteous
paul offered the following reason as to
why god revealed the law to moses and
the israelites
now we know that whatever the law says
it says to those who are under the law
that for this purpose every mouth may be
stopped and all the world may become
guilty before god
according to paul the law was revealed
to make us realize that it is impossible
to keep and that we are therefore all
guilty before god
let's compare this to what god has to
say about the law in the old testament
now what i am commanding you today is
not too difficult for you or beyond your
reach no the word is very near you it is
in your mouth and in your heart so you
may obey it
we can see that god says very clearly
that the law is not too difficult to
obey or beyond our reach which is the
complete opposite of what paul claimed
paul even had some very negative things
to say about the law here he called it a
curse
for as many as are of the works of the
law are under a curse
paul also had bad things to say about
his past efforts of keeping the law
here he referred to it as garbage as for
righteousness based on the law faultless
but whatever word gains to me i now
consider loss for the sake of christ i
consider them garbage
again such negativity is at odds with
what the old testament teaches for i
command you today to love the lord your
god to walk in obedience to him and to
keep his commands decrees and laws
then you will live and increase and the
lord your god will bless you
here god stated that obeying the law
will bring one blessing and prosperity
we can see that paul's teachings about
the law completely contradict the old
testament on many points so paul cannot
have gotten his message from the same
god that inspired the old testament
the bible informs us that towards the
end of his ministerial career paul
visited jerusalem which was home to
thousands of christians who zealously
obeyed the law of moses we are told that
senior christians directly confronted
paul about rumors that he was preaching
against the law of moses
the next day paul and the rest of us
went to see james and all the elders
were present
then they said to paul you see brother
how many thousands of jews have believed
and all of them are zealous for the law
they have been informed that you teach
all the jews who live among the gentiles
to turn away from moses telling them not
to circumcise their children or live
according to our customs
if paul was a genuine apostle then we
should expect him to be forthcoming
about his true beliefs and teachings
let's now see how paul actually reacted
what shall we do they will certainly
hear that you have come so do what we
tell you
there are four men with us who have made
a vow
take these men
joining their purification rights and
paid their expenses so that they can
have their heads shaved
then everyone will know there is no
truth in these reports about you
the next day paul took the men and
purified himself along with them
we can see that the senior christians in
jerusalem commanded paul to undergo a
public head shaving ritual that was
derived from the law of moses
paul submissively complied with their
command thus denying the rumors that he
preached against the law of moses
now in the previous section we saw
examples of paul's negative attitude
towards a mosaic law labeling it a curse
and describing efforts to obey it as
garbage
by conducting himself in this manner
paul was being two-faced for he behaved
in one way to the faces of senior
christians and another way in his
writings
in the following examples paul wrote
that jews are the same as non-jews and
no longer bound to keep any of the
mosaic law
there is neither jew nor greek
we have been released from the law so
that we serve in the new way of the
spirit and not in the old way of the
written code
we can see that paul taught the very
things he was accused of and deceptively
denied
in this video we've examined a number of
paul's writings and found many issues
which seriously undermine his claims of
apostleship and divine inspiration
a big problem which arises from this
is the fact that paul dominates the
pages of the new testament with over
half of its books being attributed to
him
so when one reads new testament and
takes it at face value you are viewing
jesus through the lens of paul who has
been proven to be an unreliable source
sincere truth-seeking christians faced
the difficult task of peeling away
layers of myth in order to try and
arrive at the true historical jesus
god out of his mercy for mankind did not
leave us in a state of confusion
the quran was revealed and unravels
centuries of myth-making around jesus
muslims are the true followers of jesus
as thanks to the quran we have access to
and implement his original undistorted
message
to learn more about the true message of
jesus please download your free copy of
the book jesus man messenger messiah
from the link below